hey guys it's me neat code again solving
another leak code problem this time
we're doing merge
k sorted linked list before we've done
merging two sorted linked list
which is i which is an easy problem i
think it was
leak code 21 so if you haven't solved
that one yet i would recommend doing so
because it's basically
we're basically extending that problem
so
this problem is actually easier than you
might think for a leak code hard problem
there's some really basic ideas that we
can use
to solve it efficiently so to illustrate
that i have
four single node linked lists right so
each of these link lists only has one
node right so five for example
so basically how can we merge them in an
efficient way let me show you
uh like the general idea so first we can
merge these two five and seven right so
the first two nodes
when we merge them we know that the five
is smaller than the seven so we put the
five
first so now we have a partially so uh
a partial linked list so now we want to
get the next value which is 3 and we
want to merge it
into this linked list again
the 3 is smaller than the beginning of
the linked list which is the 5 over here
right
so we can just put the three at the
beginning
and next we only have one value left so
we want to merge
this eight into our linked list and so
what's the general idea of how to do
that well we're gonna have to
take our eight right look at look at
this three right well it's bigger than
the three so we're not putting it
there is it bigger than the five yep is
it bigger than the seven
yep so we're going to put it at the end
so notice how we had to iterate through
every single node to find where to put
8 that's kind of a problem but we did
find the output
the output is going to be the 3 5 7 and
8.
so doing it this way is not the most
efficient way to do it because
notice for each node or linked list
we're going to be merging it into our
current output or our current
you know result we're going to be
merging it that's not going to be super
efficient we have k
lists right and the total number of
nodes we have is
n so every time we're merging a list
we're gonna potentially have to iterate
through every single node we have so far
which could be big o of n
so the overall time complexity is gonna
be k times
n now i bet you already know where i'm
going with the solution now because the
picture
really makes it obvious why would we
merge it like
this when we're
by doing that we're really repeating a
lot of work that's really not the most
efficient way to do it if you know
the algorithm merge sort you know that
there's a better way to do this
so and it's a really basic idea right
like
why merge it that way when we can merge
these two
and merge these two eliminate a bit of
that repeated work
right and then when we have that
like the five and the seven now
using this we're going to merge these
two together
as well and and assuming you know the
algorithm to merge two sorted linked
lists
you we will get the standard we'll get
the same solution right
but let's analyze what exactly is going
on here when we did this
first step right over here when we
went from four linked lists right one
two three
four and then we went to just two of
them remaining right
we did have to iterate we did have to go
through every single node so this was
a o of n operation right so it's still
not cheap it's o of n but the question
is
how many times do we have to do this in
this case we only have to do it two
times right
so we did the same thing we took our two
linked lists down here
and merged them into our result
and again we had to potentially iterate
through
every single one of our four nodes so it
was an o of
n operation but basically what we're
doing is we're taking our lists
and dividing them by two every time so
how many times can we take
the k lists and divide them by two well
it's going to be
log k this is the part where we
speed up our algorithm it's log k it's
the log k
is the number of times we're repeating
this o of
n step so in this case with this
algorithm
the total time complexity is going to be
n
log k
and that's a lot better than the brute
force which was
n times k right so this is a lot better
okay so now let's actually get into the
code
uh remember that we have to understand
how to merge
two sorted linked lists so i'm just
gonna put
that function here right now so we'll
have list one and list two as parameters
and we'll return
the output list i'm not even going to do
this yet because we know
this is not the most important part of
the algorithm that's the leak code easy
portion
we want to do the real part of the
problem which is merging
k linked list so the first thing i'm
going to handle is the annoying edge
cases where
maybe the list is null or
or the list is of length zero
in that case we can just return an empty
linked list
and now to get to the actual problem so
we're basically going to be taking
pairs of linked lists and merging them
each time
and we're going to keep doing this until
there's only one
linked list remaining and that's going
to be our output so
while the length of lists is greater
than one we're going to keep
reducing it right we're going to keep
cutting it in half
so as we merge these lists i'm going to
put them
in a new list called merged list
so now we want to iterate through each
of these lists
and each time we're going to we know we
want to do
pairs of linked lists so my incrementer
is going to be 2.
so list 1 is just going to be
at index i now list 2
might be out of bounds right because if
we have an
odd number of lists and we're
incrementing by 2 each time
list 2 could be null so we have to check
for that we'll say it's lists of i
plus 1 the adjacent list but we want to
make sure
so if i plus 1 is in bounds so we'll
check
i plus 1 is less than the length
of the list then we'll do that otherwise
we're going to say it's none if it's
none that's still
okay right because merging one non-null
linked list and one null linked list is
perfectly fine we can still do that
i want to take these two lists merge
them together
with my helper function which i haven't
even written yet
and i want to take this and append it to
our merged lists
variable over here where we are storing
the lists after we merge them
this is the way i like to do it but i've
seen people do it a different way
but now so we want to update our lists
variable because that's where we're
uh you know actually getting our lists
from so i'm going to update it with
merged lists so merge list is basically
like a temporary variable
and of course we're going to keep doing
that until there's only one list left
and then we're going to return that list
so list
of zero so see that really wasn't
too bad i mean you might uh kind of
struggle with a little bit of the edge
cases that's perfectly fine but once you
get the idea you see it's really not
that bad now we've reduced it to
an easy problem we know how to merge two
linked lists i've done it before in a
video but i'll
type it out again really quickly and
maybe if you're lucky your interviewer
won't even want you to
merge the list anyway but
let me go ahead and show off and try to
speedrun it and hopefully not have a bug
and embarrass myself
and i'm speedrunning it i'm showing off
but i literally solved this problem
right before i recorded this video so
uh it's not really a show off
i'm br i'm basically typing basically
off of memory so
just get this over with
and i'm a super slow typer once you guys
honestly once you guys practice enough
lead code you'll probably be 10 times
better than me and wonder
okay so let's dummy.
okay and once again let me prove to
myself that i don't have any bugs
and i do so okay so it was pretty small
uh merged lists dot append
we're appending to the output or
appending to this list
and hopefully that is good enough okay
of course i get messed up with the typos
merged list i guess the confusing part
was that this variable name is
pretty similar to this function name
probably should have done it a little
differently
okay but it does work so hopefully
you get the general idea it's not too
bad of a problem
there are actually a lot of ways to
solve it even a heap solution
but i think kind of sticking with this
is fine
but thank you so much for watching
hopefully this was helpful if you have
any tips and tricks you can feel free to
share them with me and feel free to
suggest
any other problems that you would like
me to solve and i'll see you
pretty soon maybe